Dearest gentle viewer, season 2 of Bridgerton
is practically abuzz, or should I say awash,
with scandalously hidden easter eggs and secret
details you might have missed.
And this author has been honing her skills
to reveal the most truly delectable morsels
to you.
Be forewarned:
spoilers ahead!
There's a sneaky reference to author Julia
Quinn, who wrote the Bridgerton novels, in
Anthony's list of potential brides to interview.
Among the names he's written in his notebook
is Lady Julia, who's characterized as "a romantic"
and Miss Quinn, who he's noted down as "an
exceptional writer";
both of whom, like the other ladies, are amusingly
struck off the list by the incredibly exacting
viscount.
Bees have been buzzing around Bridgerton since
the show began, and they're back this season,
and not just in flashbacks to Edmund's death.
At the races, Anthony claims to bet on a horse
named Nectar as it's
Well-bred, highly trained, and well-favoured
while Kate thinks he simply picked the same
horse as everyone else, but really it's another
example of the show's persistent bee imagery.
Nectar is the sugary fluid plants produce
that bees collect to make honey.
So, given the strong connection between the
Bridgertons and bees, it's no wonder that
Anthony was subconsciously drawn to a horse
by that name.
And, of course, Anthony's fear of bees is
what leads to that scandalous situation with
Kate in both the show and books.
As well as that, nectar is associated with
the idea of immortality as it's said to be
the drink of Greek and Roman gods, but in
the books Anthony is convinced that he will
die at a young age just like his father.
This season, fans get to see one of their
best-loved scenes from the books: the Bridgertons'
croquet-like game of pall-mall, which "is
less about winning than making sure the other
players lose".
It is a poor player who plays the game, and
a wise one who plays their opponent.
The TV show takes two different pall-mall
matches from the novels and mashes them up
to create their own version of this fan-favourite
moment.
While The Viscount Who Loved Me, the book
this season's based on, has Kate intentionally
knocking Anthony's ball down the hill and
into the lake, an epilogue that takes place
15 years later sees her deliberately create
a muddy puddle with her tea in order to mess
up Anthony's game, only to end up covered
in mud herself.
As in the books, Kate is the player who gets
to wield the black mallet, nicknamed the 'mallet
of death' by the Bridgerton family.
The mallet of death.
Would you look at that, Brother?
But there's an interesting extra layer of
meaning to this in the TV show as Anthony
calls the game to an end after Kate's mallet
of death accidentally hits her ball over towards
Anthony's dead father's memorial stone.
Notice this painting in Lord Featherington's
study of a shipwreck in progress which is
a nice hint to the state of the Featherington
family and their finances in much of Season
2,
as well as how terribly Jack's business ventures
went overseas in America, and it also foreshadows
the disastrous outcome of his and Lady Featherington's
scheme to make money in London with fake rubies.
After revealing Penelope as Lady Whistledown
to us at the end of last season, this season
we get to see exactly how she goes about running
her society gossip business, including how
she masquerades as Lady W's maid to bargain
with the printer of her scandal sheet.
Printers in this town are ten-a-penny.
But there's only one Lady Whistledown.
And the accent Penelope puts on as she pretends
to be Whistledown's maid is a nod to actress
Nicola Coughlan's Irish roots.
Speaking of Penelope's secret outings, notice
that the blue hooded cape she wears to disguise
her identity during her visits to the printer
is a look that's mirrored on occasions by
Eloise when she visits the printers, for example,
to try and uncover Lady W's identity in the
final episode.
Not only is that pale blue in total contrast
to Penelope's usual style, enforced by her
mother, but it also emphasises Pen's close
connection with Eloise, whose family's signature
colour is blue.
On top of that, that Eloise and Pen are dressed
alike highlights the fact that in both the
books and the show, some characters believe
Eloise is actually Lady Whistledown.
I know it is you.
Lady Whistledown herself.
There's a nice bit of foreshadowing during
the ball the Bridgertons throw in the seventh
episode.
When no one turns up except the Sharmas, Anthony
decides they should still make the best of
the evening.
There shall be dancing.
And as the two families dance together, they
do so around the Bridgerton crest, whose Latin
motto means "Family Before All", a nice nod
to the fact that these two families will actually
be united by the end of the series, after
Kate and Anthony marry.
The tulips that Anthony brings Kate after
she recovers are an interesting choice of
flower as last season his mother Violet told
him that:
Tulips.
They symbolize passion.
Perhaps your bride would like the same.
That bouquet of tulips is also a hat-tip to
the novels where Anthony plucks a tulip for
Kate from the Aubrey Hall gardens, which his
mother has filled with them as they're one
of her favourite flowers.
Given the showrunner's love of the '90s BBC
adaptation of Pride & Prejudice, it's hardly
surprising that, just like the Duke Simon
in Season 1, this season's leading man Anthony
also gets a Mr Darcy-style scene when, after
sharing a moment with Kate, he trips over
her dog and lands in the lake.
Refreshing indeed.
Come now.
It is not proper to stare.
The whole scene is also a hat-tip to the Bridgerton
books where Newton accidentally knocks Edwina
into a lake and Anthony wades in to help her
out.
Oh, and, Anthony gets a bonus Mr Darcy moment
when, like the Pride & Prejudice star,
I shall conquer this.
he works out his troubles about his leading
lady during a fencing match.
It is time for me to secure my final victory
for the day.
Bridgerton's trip to the Royal Races channels
the mid-60s movie musical My Fair Lady.
The way Kate's excitement at seeing the horses
fly by breaks through her usually very controlled
demeanour
Come now, High Flyer!
Steady!
[whistles loudly]
Should we separate them?
It's all in good spirit.
is a homage to how Cockney flower seller Eliza
Doolittle reacts at the racecourse:
Come on Dover, move your blooming a!*$!
That kind of behaviour also gets Prudence
Featherington rebuked by her mother:
Stop hollering like a newsboy.
At the start of the season, Kate's appearance
reflects both her uncompromising character
and the pressure of ensuring her younger sister
makes a good marriage match for herself and
to save the family from ruin.
So, generally, she has a more buttoned-up
look, her outfits are very structured and
made of heavier fabric such as silk taffeta,
and her hair is more controlled in contrast
to her slightly lighter and freer look as
she opens up and relaxes more as the season
progresses.
Costume designer Sophie Canale has said she
took cues from India for some of the Sharmas'
outfits, from colours and prints to jewellery
design.
Compared to the more demure Edwina, who favours
softer, paler outfits, Kate's clothes are
much bolder in colour, reflecting her personality
and tendency to speak her mind.
Anthony's sideburns were trimmed down this
season to signal how he's changed since his
rakish days in Season 1 and is taking a more
mature view of his role as viscount with all
its responsibilities including his search
for a wife.
For Penelope's gown at the Diamond Ball, the
show's designers have said they channelled
princess of pop Kylie Minogue's showgirl look
from her Greatest Hits/Homecoming tour.
Like Kylie's outfit, Penelope's shimmering
dress has a wealth of stars across the torso
and there are even more in her hair.
While Pen's costume is in her signature yellow,
rather than blue like Kylie's, curiously in
the moonlight, some of the stars on Pen's
dress do actually look blue!
Just as each of the show's families has their
own distinctive colours for their costumes,
the same is true of their houses.
Check out the Bridgertons' home and you'll
see that the palette of blues, silvers, and
pastels in their outfits is also reflected
throughout their house, from the sofas and
chairs to the rugs, curtains, ornaments, tea
sets, much of the clothing in various portraits,
the fireplace, and even the family carriage!
When it comes to the Featheringtons, their
ostentatious fashion choices are all about
standing out
Look at me, everyone!
and so is their home, with its emphasis on
lots and lots of gold, and that includes their
social gatherings.
Gold flowers, gold drinks, gold everywhere.
And their home also features rich greens and
plenty of citrus tones, especially yellows.
Then there's Lady Danbury's house which complements
both her own style and her guests, the Sharmas,
with shades of pink, peach, and gold.
Season 2 finds Eloise settled in her sister
Daphne's old bedroom.
So, there's plenty of books, as she's much
more interested in literature than the marriage
mart;
Might I go and read now?
And you'll also spot a portrait of Mary Wollstonecraft,
whose early feminist works Eloise has been
reading, preferring them to Whistledown's
gossip:
My own sex, I hope, will excuse me if I treat
them like rational creatures, instead of flattering
their fascinating graces.
Wollstonecraft.
Despite her protests, Eloise begins the season
trussed up to make her society debut, but
she still manages to maintain a sense of her
more rebellious nature in her everyday attire.
We often see her in striped or checked patterns
as well as waistcoats and spencer jackets,
giving her costumes a more "masculine" twist,
according to the show's designer.
There's a sneaky little meta-joke hidden among
Lady Whistledown's Society Papers when the
queen of gossip takes a moment off from reporting
the ton's tittle-tattle to write a book review.
When Lady W describes the difference between
the author's previous books compared to his
latest, it's almost as if she's describing
the difference between the two seasons of
Bridgerton itself.
So, Season 1 was more elusive and subtle,
leaving viewers "constantly guessing" Whistledown's
identity.
However, with that already unveiled to the
audience, in Season 2 there's considerably
"less guessing and more waiting for the other
characters to become aware of the events"
that we already know!
Well that would explain the ink all over her
fingers.
Now, if you want to protect yourself online
from snoopers like Lady Whistledown, long-time
viewers know we recommend everyone use a quality
VPN like Nord, that encrypts your internet
connection and conceals your IP address, so
you can keep all your online activity private.
However, with a standard VPN you can still
be tracked online by third-party cookies and
those horrible intrusive ads that follow you
from website to website.
Then there's that creepy feeling when Facebook
starts showing you ads for something you were
just searching for, like your obsession with
Regency houses.
Fortunately, Nord have just launched their
new Threat Protection feature, which blocks
trackers and annoying and intrusive ads, making
your online experience a lot cleaner, safer,
and enjoyable.
On top of that, it will protect you if you
accidentally stumble across a shady site or
phishing link that downloads a malicious file
to take over your device.
Nord's Threat Protection will scan any sites
you visit and files you download for malware
and if a threat is found, the file is deleted
immediately.
With Nord, you can connect up to six devices
at any one time so you can protect all your
phones, laptops and computers.
For a limited time, all our viewers can grab
a very special offer of a huge 72% off a 2-year
plan, plus a bonus month and Threat Protection
completely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/FLICKS or go to the
link in the video description to get the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
So, what did you think of season 2 of Bridgerton?
And did you notice any little details or easter
eggs?
Leave your comments below!
Next, tap left to discover all the clues and
secret bees you missed the first time around
in Season 1.
And if you enjoyed this video, do leave a
thumbs-up and share it with your friends,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying this show with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!